so remember as VFR pilot
she's gonna be doing stuff that is in
some ways more challenging than what
airline pilots do because you're always
trying to keep clearances from clouds
that the IFR pilots don't care about and
if you're flying a low performance
airplane you're also dealing with you
know flying through the leather instead
of it's going on top of it so while
you're the VFR only pilot these
non-local flights really pay attention
to whether airspace go and study this a
little bit before the exam here are the
different kinds remember Class A is up
high in an instrument clearance Class B
is around the biggest airports class
Charlie's around Manchester New
Hampshire and D is for Hanscom and E is
kind of everywhere else okay
the goal for the basic VFR weather
minimums is to make sure that an IFR
plane coming out of the cloud has time
to see and avoid you because the air
traffic controllers job is to separate
IFR airplanes from each other not to
separate IFR and VFR traffic they will
tell you about them but you're
responsible as the VFR pilot for staying
reasonably clear of clouds so just
review these cloud clearances Class E
you can see that this is a pretty good
one to remember for the test 500 below a
thousand above two thousand horizontally
if you're really low in Class G airspace
you can do some crazy stuff again I
don't think this is really there to let
you you know go from Boston to Chicago
Scott running with you know one mile of
visibility and just clear of the clouds
I think it's more to enable people to
say take off and do pattern work at
their home Airport in some kind of
little tiny very slow airplane pattern
work is just what we were drying on the
chalk board flying the traffic pattern
at an airport
so again yeah just review the
presentation or the fa book so you know
your weather minimums
yeah incredibly at night for class G
getting back to that pattern work thing
if you want to go out and practice
takeoffs and landings at night if you
stay within half a mile of the runway
you can go right down to one mile of
visibility and right off right up to the
clouds
okay here's that chart again learn it
know it special VFR actually if you're
at Hanscom and the weather is below the
basic minimums and you say you want to
do some pattern work anyway either in a
helicopter or an airplane you can
request they can't offer it but you can
request a special VFR clearance and
they'll say okay there's not too much
higher traffic right now so you you know
take off and land and do your do your
stuff if it's a night you'll have to be
an IFR pilot basically cirrus publishes
this good personal minimum matrix I
wouldn't say that you have to adopt
their specific numbers but I think their
way of thinking isn't bad so notice
they're saying you know if you are let's
see an average pilot so you've got you
know ten IFR hours within the last 90
days you've done you know one not on out
of it approach within the last 90 days
I'll go over here and go down to a 500
foot ceiling in two miles of visibility
don't go down to the published approach
minimums which are designed for a two
pilot professional crew unless you know
you're very current you've done a whole
bunch of flying in the last 90 days
anyway so they just try to fit they try
to say how challenging is this like how
experienced are you in general how
experienced are you recently and come up
with some numbers so again you can pull
this out of the slide and just to
clarify what we're talking about when we
talk about personal minimums so there
there are minimums that you have to know
for the FAA exam like we were just
talking about in terms of the minimum
visibility that must be
there in order to for you to fly in
certain classes of airspace but then
there are also minimums that you set on
yourself to be a safe pilot and to be
kind of knowledgeable about what your
restrictions and what your experience
and what your currency is so for example
we talked about crosswind so there isn't
an FA reg necessarily you know as long
as it's within your aircraft's operating
conditions there's no specific reason
why you know a 15 or 20 knot crosswind
is a problem but maybe you're not very
comfortable with it you haven't done a
lot of slips recently you're still
getting used to your aircraft so you
might say you know a smaller crosswind
or gusting winds would be appropriate
for you to land it so that's setting a
personal minimum on yourself and this
this is an example of personal minimums
based on your experience and your
currency and the FAA will never suggest
this but the appropriate escape from you
know a challenging situation that you
think might be on the edge of safety is
to rent the five-seat sr22 instead of
the forc'd sr20 and go with an
instructor so it's as easy as that
ok remember this was confusing they use
category in class to mean totally two
totally different things for getting
your pilot's certificate the category is
there on the left something like an
airplane versus a rotorcraft
and the class would be you know multi
engine land versus helicopter category
class but then for aircraft they do
something totally different and they say
category would be you know normal
category or acrobatic and class would be
airplane so they may ask you about this
just because they like the torque for
you the four forces of flight remember
these Tina talked about them if you're
just bombing along straight and level
not accelerating then they're gonna all
be in balance because F equals MA
equals whatever get remembers math
anyway F equals MA I know that much
remember the three axes they'll ask you
about this on the test usually in
combination with some other stuff so
rotation about the vertical axis is
going to be yaw rotation about the this
is complicated let's see rotation about
the lateral axis is going to be pitch
rotation around the longitudinal axis I
believe will be roll so that's a little
bit confusing since yeah here we have it
pitch roll yaw right so think about it
roll is really the lateral motion but
it's around the longitudinal axis so
don't get confused there remember why
Johnny Cessna can't hover is also a
limit for this is this limits everything
basically the stalling angle of attack
is why you need a helicopter if you want
to hover and it is why you need to
maintain a reasonable airspeed when
you're a landing and it's also it limits
your runway right if you had an airplane
that didn't stall till it reached some
crazy angle attack you could probably
take off and land in 50 feet right and
remember that we talked about even a
paper airplane can generate lift so it's
not about the shape of the cross section
of the wing that is making you be able
to generate lift it's the angle of
attack and your ability to deflect air
molecules down that's what generates
lift that shape of the airfoil is just
what Philip was saying that allows you
to have the stall speed be lowered all
right so remember your left-turning
tendencies mostly you just remember that
you need right rudder and a couple
questions had come up on gyroscopic
precession so I added two videos about
gyroscopes to help you understand
gyroscopic precession and why that force
is applied 90 degrees later and
those are really fun videos you can look
at their in the slide deck called QA and
review ok so let's go back to the
altitudes so true altitude is your
actual height above sea level this is
what's important if you want to get over
on mountain because the altitude on the
chart for the mountain is also the
actual height above sea level indicated
it's what your L Timoner shows if you're
below 18,000 feet and it's not some
insane temperature and you've got a
current altimeter setting from air
traffic control as you fly along with
VFR advisories they'll keep updating you
with altitudes if you're not talking to
ATC you know you may to nin to the
airports that you're flying over to get
the altimeter there if you have your
correctly set altimeter it should be
pretty close to your true altitude but
and the GPS will give it to you as well
all right absolute height above the
ground I don't think that's ever really
relevant pressure altitude is what you
see if you tune your altimeter to to
nine or nine or two density is critical
for determining performance of both the
aircraft in the engine so that's a
measure of you know how many actual
molecules of air are there gonna be in a
one liter cylinder for example know your
taxiway and runway markings this has
practical value and also test value one
easy thing to remember is if you're
driving along a taxiway in your aircraft
you will see yellow paint on a black pay
of surface so that sign tells you what
taxiway that you're actually on just
like the real-world experience of yellow
paint on black everything else is kind
of reasonably self-explanatory they
probably even though if you're not an
instrument pilot they want you to know
about this ILS hold short line so if
it's kind of bad weather conditions and
they're using the ILS they don't want
you going beyond there because your
metal airplane might interfere with the
radio beams that are being sent up
- landing IFR airplanes remember L over
D max for a best glide speed so all
these climb speeds guides beads etc are
driven off of the points at which the
various drags reach a minimum or a
minimum per per mile traveled
thunderstorms
the one thing you I hope you do remember
is that everything is bad about
convective clouds unstable air leads to
cumulus clouds they can become
cumulonimbus clouds and now you have a
really bad hazard aviation with terrible
icing terrible turbulence may be hail so
the squall line I think they sometimes
ask about this on the test the frontal
band of thunderstorms so just you know
it's hard to get around them and you
know you may have to go 500 miles out of
your way to get around the cold front or
hang out on the ground for a few hours
and wait for it to pass
also just big changes in weather usually
are not a good thing so whether it's a
big change in the barometric pressure or
as we saw from yesterday today to today
like a 4050 degree increase in the
temperature it's going to be accompanied
by massive gusting winds today is not a
good day to go flying yeah although
actually it might not just be the day it
might be you know now referring the
helicopter from Los Angeles back to
Boston and you know there was a
thunderstorm coming in so we just landed
in an airport it was probably gusting
about 30 knots at the time which isn't
that bad for Robinson the four-seat
Robinson but the helicopter and a hangar
you know there's a huge storm and the
two hours later later we took off in
beautiful weather and continued our
flight so don't you know there is an
airport usually every 10 or 15 minutes
of flight time so take advantage of that
if things are getting beyond your
comfort zone don't just blindly continue
to your destination so remember the lee
side of mountains is where you can get a
lot of turbulence and downdrafts a
little airplane doesn't have a whole lot
of kind performance usually especially
up in higher altitudes
so be cautious about crossing big
mountain ranges unless the winds law
forecast is for very light winds indeed
icing also super bad again as the VFR
pilots you shouldn't have to worry about
this once you get into instrument flying
that's a help a lot of you will this is
really what limits your ability to
travel around in a piper Cessna or
Cirrus during the winter and shoulder
seasons remember how to read the meats
are so this is back to Peachtree DeKalb
Airport in Atlanta so there's it's the
16th at 16 53 so about almost 5 p.m. in
London Zulu time winds are variable at
410 statute miles of visibility overcast
6000 feet that's 6,000 feet above the
airport not above sea level
temps 14 dew points -7 altimeter three
zero one five oh and in the remarks it
says the rain ended 46 minutes after the
hour there you have it
alright human factor summary so you are
the weakest link and if you develop some
personal minimums you'll be way ahead of
the game
they should also factor in your recent
experience not just your overall level
of flying and always remember that it's
a big aviation community there's a lot
of people are happy to go flying
you can send mail to the members of the
MIT Flying Club and just take a copilot
that's how the airlines have cut risk
almost to zero magnetic variation this
is kind of a topic that tends to snag
people on the knowledge test so just
remember you can read arrived it from
the vor if you ever get stuck and East
is leased West is best deviation then
don't don't get deviation and variation
confused so deviation remember
is that tiny little correction that's
printed right underneath the compass
flight planning tip you saw this slide
earlier even the far 61 and far 91 allow
it and doesn't mean it's wise so if you
look at far 121 and far 135 for charter
and scheduled airline service they show
you that there's some extra safety
margins that can be built in night
flying advice you just heard remember is
the owner/operator you're responsible
for keeping the airplane air worthy if
you do choose to go out and buy an
aircraft so these responsibilities are
you know for most of you going to be on
the flight school however you're still
the final authority as the pilot and you
can deviate from the rules in an
emergency and you only have to report
the deviation if requested I think that
the feds like to ask this on the
knowledge test because the natural
answer is of course you have to report
the deviation and I declared it an
emergency and I broke the rules but you
don't actually have to report that
unless they ask you to but even aside
from an emergency you're the pilot and
command even if someone very assertively
tells you to land and hold short or to
fly straight to the numbers which means
don't fly the profit proper traffic
pattern but but land very quickly or
tells you you know no delay on the go
because they want you to get out quickly
they have other jets
you can just say unable and they have to
deal with it and make sure you're flying
safely and if you especially as a
student pilot need extra time or extra
consideration just add student pilot to
the end of all your radio calls and
they'll give you plenty of room to make
mistakes but they might also make you
sit there and fly a bunch of 360s while
they land everybody else and then give
you time and yeah so safety is not high
tech it should be probably you know we
should actually all the stuff that
Michael showed you that's embedded in
that DJI drone should probably be in
these multi-million dollar aircraft but
it's not so in the meantime
you know since an airliner isn't
actually that much smarter than a little
Cessna you know why is it safer and if
you take that perspective and just adapt
all the things the airlines have done
you can make flying that little Cessna
dramatically safer
so that means recurrent training you
know maybe go up with an instructor
every three months instead of the every
two years that the FAA requires the
instrument flying skills are really
important for VFR safety they make you a
much better pilot you know at night as
we've just discussed and even bombing
around during the day you'll be able to
fly with about five percent of your
mental energy instead of 50% if you are
an instrument-rated pilot on a nice VFR
day the two pilot crew and checklist is
really the cornerstone of the airline
safety system so and you can take
advantage of that as a ga pilot even
though the FA you know really about 5%
of the FAA which is the one you've seen
and interacted with it's all about
encouraging people to be single pilots
and 95% of the FAA is about forbidding
people to operate single pilot every
part of the FAA that regulates you know
the airlines and charters of sizeable
airplanes they say no of course you
can't operate a single pilot that would
be incredibly dangerous alright so just
remember study a little bit about the
part 61 and part 91 for learning - we
know what does it take to be and
maintain your status as a pilot or being
able to exercise your privileges as a
pilot that certificate never expires
part 91 is about what you can do with an
airplane operated privately and then
there's this little corner over there
under title 49 part 830 having to do
with accident reporting and
investigation if you want to get a
hundred on the fa knowledge test a lot
of East Coast Aero Club customers seem
to over study I see a lot of 95 97 98
and 100's actual 100's just reread the
FAA text
I mean they can't ask you anything
that's not in one of their own PDFs that
includes the far aim though the the
regulations and the aeronautical
information manual there are test prep
books and all nine equivalents that are
worth it to finish this course actually
you can get this you'll be able to get
actually we don't even need to email you
because if you have the course homepage
you can see it here you go to this king
school thing and you say you want to do
60 questions 60 is a number of questions
on the actual exam so we're making our
final exam being the same and then you
start test and you send us the results
and we'll be happy
all right next steps if you want to
continue your journey beyond this class
maybe that's for the one or two people
that applies that actually want to
continue their journey can I borrow the
pointer for just a second this for the
guys that we're getting tripped up
thinking it was a river that's exactly
what we're talking about this is a
Boston Logan these blue lines circles
that are rounded are not rivers it's
indicating that class Bravo airspace and
I have it open over here if you want to
take a look okay so yeah join the flying
club go visit a flight school most of
the busier US airports have some kind of
flight school that you can do and yeah
in the two hours that are remaining to
me for this presentation I would just
like to say thank you now we're saying
thank you but just to clarify there's
there's a really cool guest speaker
coming next but for the purposes of our
teaching thank you very much and we'll
take any questions
you
you